Democrats pull an insane round of
manipulation regarding sexual assault
allegations against Brett Kavanaugh and
Bernie Sanders off the rails once more
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
well it's Cavanaugh Cavanaugh and more
Cavanaugh today because that is the only
thing in the news and it's the only
thing in the news for a reason I have
never seen anything like this I have
never seen people throw out an
allegation with no supporting facts
whatsoever admit that there are no
supporting facts whatsoever admit they
don't know whether the allegation is
true and still maintain that a dudes
life should be ruined over it it's
pretty unbelievable but we'll get to all
of that in just a second first let's
talk about your comfort so I took the
day off yesterday but the day that I
took off was spent in penitence and
prayer if I'd really wanted to relax
what I would have done and I shouldn't
do this on Yom Kippur but any other day
of the year what I would have done is
get a massage from the folks over at
Zeile because the only thing better than
getting a massage is getting a massage
in the comfort of your own home which is
where zeal comes in you go to zeal calm
around zeals iPhone or Android app
that's Z ee l comm and you select from
tap local licensed pre-screened massage
therapist you choose your favorite
technique gender preference time and
location for your massage zeal then
sends one of their 10,000 licensed
massage therapists with a massage table
music and supplies to give you a
five-star massage scheduling booking
payment it's fast and easy the tip is
even included 7 days a week 365 days a
year
Azul massage therapist can be at your
door and then as little as an hour it's
super convenient which is why I've
gotten this as gift for my wife for both
my parents for my in-laws for my sister
it's really fantastic it's super
convenient and the massage therapists
are all fantastic find out for yourself
why Zeile has been featured in The Wall
Street Journal New York Times Vogue and
on Good Morning America and why we talk
about it over here bring the spot to you
and try seal today today like their on
demand to get you started our listeners
can get 25 bucks off their first massage
with promo code been that Cee Elcom
promo code Ben right now again go to
zeal comm or on zeals iPhone or Android
app get a special offer when you try
zeal today enter promo code Ben's get 25
bucks off your first in-home massage so
I have to say that in the 25 hours that
I was away the Democrats have morphed
their playbook so it went from here's a
woman accusing a prospective Supreme
Court nominee of sexual assault let's
hear her story - you must not ask any
questions whatsoever and if you do you
are demonstrating you don't take her
seriously also you can't talk to her so
basically Democrat said here this
woman's story and Republicans said
okay let's hear it and Democrat said no
never and Republican said well then how
are we supposed to hear Hearst and
Democrats no never and that's pretty
much where things stand right now as in
her lawyer is now saying that there is
no reason to have a hearing that instead
they're going to throw this in the lap
of the FBI as we discussed a couple of
days ago the FBI is not the magic police
okay they don't just go around
investigating claims that are thirty six
years old with no corroborate of
evidence there's nothing for them to do
here no federal crime has actually been
alleged this notion that the the FBI is
some sort of time cop and they can just
go back in time and watch from outside
the window with their spy glasses and
then see what Brett Kavanaugh did at an
unspecified date and an unspecified time
in an unspecified location that's crazy
talk but Democrats are trying to put
that out there so they don't have to
have a hearing now this is how you know
that the allegations must not be all
that credible even to Democrats it's a
win for them to have a hearing right I
mean how does this go badly for them
think think about the logic let's say
the Democrats have this hearing let's
say that Christine Blasi for the accuser
comes forward and let's say that she
gives a tear-filled interview about
exactly what happened when Brett
Kavanaugh allegedly thrust her into a
room jumped on top of her tried to pull
her clothes down and put his hand over
her mouth while she was screaming
how exactly are Republicans gonna look
good coming out of that and this is the
assumption last week this is why so many
Republicans were saying let's not even
do this hearing right let's just go
straight to the vote the reason is
because there is no way to win that PR
battle you got a woman who is alleging
something terrible happened to her and a
bunch of old white men asking her
questions how does that come off looking
good for Republicans well the only way
it comes out looking good for
Republicans is if there are holes in her
story if it looks like Democrats took a
half-baked story threw it out there in
order to stop Cavanaugh and then her
story falls apart publicly that's the
only plausible reason why Democrats
don't actually want to hold this hearing
don't believe them when they say well we
we have to shield the accuser from the
pain of having to go through the story
again she's already told her story
publicly people are already sending
death threats they shouldn't be because
that's evil but people are already doing
that so the idea that she is going to
minimize the pain that she's feeling by
not testifying is totally insane plus
they could have this hearing behind
closed doors
in fact that's what senator
grassley is calling for Grassley has put
out a long letter to the Democrats is
exactly right he says dear mrs. cats and
banks that would be the lawyers for this
woman cuz thank you for your letter
dated September 18th 2018 I was
disturbed to read that your clients and
her family have received threats of
intimidation that's never appropriate
and no one should be subject to that
behavior
the FBI has supplemented Judge
Cavanaugh's background investigation
file in light of the allegations raised
by her client dr. Christine Blasi Ford
the committee standard procedure for
supplemented background investigations
is to conduct phone or in-person
interviews with the relevant parties to
discuss the underlying issues to that
end
committee staff has attempted to contact
you directly by phone and email several
times to schedule a call at a time
convenient for you and your client we
thus far have not heard back from you
with regards to that request
shocker please contact committee staff
ear earliest convenience to schedule
that call at a time convenient for you
and your client as you know I have
reopened the hearing on judge
Cavanaugh's nomination in light of dr.
Ford's allegation that hearing will
begin again on Monday September 25th at
10:00 a.m. I have invited dr. Ford to
testify regarding her allegations
against judge Cavanaugh and in
recognition of how difficult it can be
to discuss allegations of this kind in
public I have also offered her the
choice of testifying in either a public
or closed session of the hearing as
Grassley writing in response to my
invitation however you wrote yesterday
that quote an FBI investigation of the
incident should be the first step in
addressing her allegations I certainly
understand and respect dr. Ford's desire
for an investigation of her allegations
that is precisely what the Senate is
doing that is why our investigators have
asked to speak with your client that is
why I've invited dr. Ford to tell her
story to the Senate and if she so
chooses to the American people it is not
the FBI's role to investigate a matter
such as this before nominating an
individual to a judicial or executive
office the White House directs the FBI
to conduct a background investigation
the FBI compiles information about a
prospective nominee and sends it to the
White House the White House then
provides FBI background investigation
files to the Senate as a courtesy to
help us determine whether to confirm a
nominee the FBI does not make a
credibility assessment of any
information it receives with respect to
a nominee nor is it tasked with
investigating a matter simply because
the committee deems it important and
they continue this Grassley again the
chairman of the Senate Judiciary
Committee have reopened the hearing
because I believe that anyone who comes
forward with allegations of sexual
assault has a right to be heard and
because it is the committee's
responsibility to
evaluate the fitness of a nominee to the
Supreme Court I therefore want to give
dr. Ford an opportunity to tell her
story to the Senate and if she chooses
to the American people I also want to
give Judge Cavanaugh an opportunity to
respond to the allegations you have
stated repeatedly that dr. Ford wants to
tell her story I sincerely hope that dr.
Ford will accept my invitation to do so
either privately or publicly on Monday
in the meantime my staff would still
welcome the opportunity to speak with
dr. Ford I remind you that consistent
with committee rules dr. Ford's prepared
testimony and biography are due to the
committee by 10:00 a.m. on Friday
September 21st if she intends to testify
on Monday and her lawyers have come back
and said no we're not gonna do any of
this hey Trump president Trump comes for
he says listen it would be wonderful if
she showed up so we could ask some
serious questions about this I think
he's an extraordinary man I think he's a
man of great intellect as I've been
telling you and he's has an unblemished
record this is a very tough thing for
him and his family and we want to get it
over with at the same time we want to
give tremendous amounts of time if she
shows up that would be wonderful if she
doesn't show up that would be
unfortunate and of course that's exactly
right again it's exactly right when
Trump is saying that forget we think of
Trump she has to show up so that we
actually have some sort of questions
that can be asked of this woman instead
what we're getting from the left is how
dare you how dare you we tell a story
either believe it or don't but we're not
giving you anything we're not giving you
anything you by this standard it's not
even worthwhile for the woman to have
come forward Dianne Feinstein should
have just said there's an anonymous
allegation that Brett Kavanaugh sexually
assaulted someone in his teens we're not
coming forward with who she is we're not
coming for with any information about
what happened we're not talking about
where when why how or who we're not
gonna talk about any of those things and
you must respect our anonymous
allegation there's a reason that there's
such a thing as due process of law when
it comes to the criminal courts and
there should be at least a modicum of
due process when it comes to the court
of public opinion as well but Dianne
Feinstein who started this whole charade
by receiving in this letter and then not
saying anything about it for six weeks
waiting till after Cavanaugh's hearing
waiting until after all of her written
questions wait until after all of her
verbal questions to Cavanaugh and the
releasing that that notice that she had
this letter that was anonymous
information from an anonymous individual
even Dianne Feinstein is now saying I
can't say everything is truthful well if
you can't say everything is truthful
then what the hell are we doing this for
if you can't say that you believe the
accuser and what are we doing this for
and on what basis you believe the
accuser and what you think the process
should be going forward and no it
doesn't help to just say throw it to the
FBI I accuse Dianne Feinstein of eating
small babies I don't you ask me what my
evidence is I don't have to show you my
evidence that you eat small babies I
just all I can say is I know that in the
back room Dianne Feinstein takes small
children carves them up into little bits
eats their spleen liver and appendix and
then proceeds to boil their legs and eat
them too and if you ask me
what basis I have for such allegations
all I can say is let's let the FBI look
into it let's let the FBI check it out
you don't have the right to ask me those
sorts of questions and if you ask me
those sorts of questions it's because
you don't care about babies being eaten
in the back room by old senators you
don't care about any of that stuff you
know who I know because you're asking me
questions if you didn't care you would
just finish Dianne Feinstein's career
this is really disgusting stuff here's
Dianne Feinstein saying yesterday I
don't know that everything is truthful I
really know who knows well I have no say
I'm the lead Democrat but the
Republicans control so this is all up to
the Republican side okay and I think
it's really too bad that no one called
her or called her lawyer my
understanding is she got emails and this
is a woman and I really believe who's
been profoundly impacted by this now I
can't say everything's truthful I don't
know but I do know that you had to
contact her lawyers and our side isn't
putting this together the Republican
side is putting it together this is
insane okay this is just insane they
didn't call her
they only emailed what so sure seen the
emails you know about it don't you
people respond by email all the time I
do it on a frequent basis email is a
form of communication in 2018 it turns
out what in the world
and then there's Ford's lawyer so Ford's
where comes
fourth and she says listen you know we
put out these allegations but why should
we rush to a hearing there's no rush
let's be real about what this is folks
this is a delaying tactic Democrats are
hoping now this whole thing drags all
the way through the election all they
have to do is drag the sucker out
another six weeks if they can drag it
past the election they're hoping
desperately the democrats clean up in
the election there's about a one in two
to one in three chance that they
actually win the Senate back let's say
they win the Senate back and then they
just stifle Cavanaugh's nomination in
the same way Republicans stifled Merrick
Garland's nomination they could do that
and that's their great hope here that's
what they're doing this looks like a
political hit again maybe the lady's
telling the truth
she is not providing any evidence that
she's telling the truth like none okay
her saying something I've had bad things
happen to me in my life and I could
provide you if I if I wanted to bring
them forth I could provide you
corroborate of detail I could provide
you witnesses I could provide you time
in place okay and these are things that
happen like let's see when I was 15 so
19 years ago so it's a long time though
two decades ago I could ride you time in
place I can tell you what date it was I
can tell you where it happened okay and
if I couldn't then you would rightly ask
me what evidence I have of my
allegations we can get more into this in
just one second but first let's talk
about your Aero filters listen I know
sexy topic I know you don't want to hear
about your air filters but let's be real
the reason you need to hear about your
air filters is because you are breathing
in gunk right now it's just seeping into
your lungs that gunk and that is why you
ought to have air filters that are
actually clean then actually worked
apparel haven't thought about your
filters for years that's your problem
if you had thought about your air
filters they'd be clean right now and
this is where filter by comes in filter
by makes sure that you have clean air
filters in they can do pretty much any
size okay go to filter by comm it's
America's leading provider of HVAC
filters for homes and small businesses
you can choose from over 600 sizes
including custom options they ship free
within 24 hours you just go and you
register and then you can even get on a
regular schedule so you never have to
think about air filters again every time
I mention air filters you won't have to
think about it because you already took
care of it they support working
Americans manufacturing all their
filters right here in the United States
save 5% when you subscribe for auto
replacement so you're never gonna forget
to change your filters filter by will
save you time and money you're gonna
breathe better
apparently become more intelligent in
the process when you're not breathing
gunk so stop procrastinating right now
that's filter by comm filter bu why comm
tell them I sent you we use it here at
Daily wire offices because again we
don't want our employees breathing gunk
we want them to be smart and with it and
not dying of cancer so go check it out
right now filter by comm and tell them
we sent you get on that regular
schedules too so because you save 5%
when you subscribe for auto replacement
so this lady's lawyer comes for us and
and she says there's no reason to rush
to a hearing oh so there's a reason to
rush to bring out the allegation but
there's no reason to rush to a hearing
mm-hmm so here is the statement from
Christine blaze Ford's lawyer Lisa banks
quote dr. Ford was reluctantly thrust
into the public spotlight only two days
ago let's be clear about why dr. forum
was thrust into the public spotlight she
sends a letter to the Washington Post to
representative Anna Eshoo of California
and to Dianne Feinstein in all three of
those letters she said she wanted to
keep it confidential if there was a real
basis for the allegations like a hard
evidentiary basis don't you think the
Washington Post would have reported it
they reported the ROI more allegations
don't you think they would have checked
it out go on and vetted it down to the
ground but they couldn't and so instead
Dianne Feinstein leaked anonymous
allegations out into the public and then
shock of shocks it turns out that the
lady feels like she needs to come
forward because now it's public enough
that people are tracking her down weird
how that works we're done that sort of
media manipulation works you release a
letter to a politician you say keep my
name out of it the politician releases
the letter without your name in it and
two days later you are coming forth
whose fault is it that this whole thing
was released dianne feinstein's okay she
is currently unable to go home and is
receiving ongoing threats to her and her
family safety listen I know what that
feels like it's terrible
it is terrible and obviously evil nobody
should be threatening anybody else in
the United States with violence that's
not a thing but that doesn't mean you
get to hide behind safety threats not to
testify about matters that impact the
entire fate of the Supreme Court going
forward her lawyer says fairness and
respect for her situation dictates you
should have time to deal with this no
that is not what fairness and respect
dictate that is not fairness and respect
it ain't fair doesn't respect ik tape
that people should be prosecuted for
threatening her they do not dictate that
she has to be given a year to deal with
the emotional pain of an allegation that
actually has impact on the public
discourse she continues to believe that
a full mana nonpartisan investigation of
this matter is needed and she's willing
to cooperate with the committee however
the committee stated plans to move
forward with a hearing that has only two
witnesses is not
fair or good-faith investigation there
multiple witnesses whose names have
appeared publicly and should be included
in any proceeding okay so why don't
Democrats just say that why don't they
say okay we'll have the hearing but
we're also gonna need to hear from our
judge and a bunch of other people
they're not doing that they're just a no
hearing which is pretty suspicious now
in a second we're gonna talk about what
Democrats are really up to here what
Democrats are really up to so what are
Democrats really up to here they're
trying to shift the entire nature of the
conversation from guilt or innocence and
toward look how mean Republicans are
okay I mean they are for even asking
questions it shows they don't understand
pain now a couple of days ago the
execrable Anna Marie Cox over on MSNBC
of our walk at she suggested that if
there was a hearing Brett Kavanaugh
wouldn't just have to demonstrate his
innocence he wouldn't even have to
debunk the case he had to show that he
understood the pain of a woman he says
is falsely accusing him of alleged rape
attempted rape hey she'd have to feel
but that's the that's the new tack so
when the Democrats don't have the facts
on their side they argue the law and
they don't have the law on their side
they argue the feelings that's that's
really what this is so kirsten
gillibrand
who is just the worst I mean kirsten
gillibrand is just a garbage human being
and this is a person who basically said
that Al Franken should be ousted from
the Senate over allegations that he was
touching women inappropriately and then
backtracked on that she switched every
position she's ever held I mean this is
a this is a person when I when people
say you have your finger in the wind to
feel which way the wind is blowing then
they shift with the wind she is a she is
the little rooster on top of the farm
house if she doesn't have her finger in
the wind
she's a weather vane she's an actual
human weather vane so here is Kirsten
Gillibrand saying the GOP is trying to
bully so let's get this right if the GOP
doesn't have a hearing that's bullying
if the GOP does have a hearing that's
bullying it seems like you might have an
unfalsifiable thesis there Kirsten here
she is explaining they are creating a
false choice they are trying to bully
her into testifying on Monday before a
full FBI background check is completed
first nomination for the Supreme Court
for any judicial nomination
there's always an FBI investigation they
do it as the part of the background
check this allegation is new
they should have at least that thorough
nonpartisan review of the facts and then
those facts can be presented to the
Senators so they can have a proper
hearing but unfortunately they're trying
to set up he said she said scenario and
bully her into either testifying on
Monday or not being heard at all no
that's what if you even got back to them
and said okay you know we're gonna
testify
Wednesday justify Friday but instead
you're getting back in you're saying
we're not testifying at all unless the
FBI does exactly what we want these are
the same folks on the Left who say the
FBI should not be used as a political
tool by the administration really these
are the same folks on the Left who are
saying Donald Trump's interference with
the FBI is politically inappropriate I
agree if you were interfering with the
FBI and yet these are folks who are now
using the FBI as a weapon against Brett
Kavanaugh knowing full well this is not
the FBI's job in this situation the
FBI's job is not to be the fact checker
for anonymous and unverifiable
allegations that is not the FBI's job
their job is to make clear to the
committee what matters they have heard
about they don't check in to the vet or
the veracity of every allegation that is
made that's insane
that's what Senate committees are for
it's their job to investigate and if
Democrats have something by the way you
think Democrats don't have investigators
on their payroll I think Democrats don't
have people who they can pay you know I
know a fusion GPS seems like they have
some time these days you think they
don't have people who can dig down and
do Apple research and research this
stuff and come up with something what
this really mostly looks like is
Democrats trying to cover for the fact
that they got nothing here
Edie Whelan over at National Review who
is not known as a guy who says
inflammatory things and we lean his
president of the ethics and Policy
Center he issued a series of posts this
week he said by one week from today
I expect the judge Cavanaugh will have
been clearly vindicated on this matter
specifically I expect that compelling
evidence will show his categorical
denial to be truthful there will be no
cloud over him senator Feinstein will
soon be apologizing to judge Cavanaugh
the accusations will have been shown to
be deeply unjust a Whelan is not a guy
to get over his skis I've dealt with
that Whelan when I had criticisms about
Brett Kavanaugh and wheelin critiques
the criticisms of Brett Kavanaugh in
some cases I think that he was totally
right like this is a guy who actually
does his research Whelan suggested that
there may be some provable wrongdoing
but not on Kavanagh
and funny how attorney didn't seek an
investigation two months ago a week from
now I doubt any fair-minded person will
think that any further investigation is
necessary at least not concerning any
alleged wrongdoing by Cavanaugh
so if Ed Whelan has some information on
this and it does break it's going to be
just humiliating for Democrats but
here's the thing Democrats don't care
whether it's true or not in the end
that's the bottom line
Democrats do not give one good damn
about whether these allegations are true
all they care about is destroying bet
Cavanaugh all they care about is
delaying this until after the election
that's all they care about in life and
I'm gonna show it to you in just a
second but first let's talk about what
you're eating
hey are you eating stuff that tastes
good are you eating stuff that is not
that expensive you're eating stuff that
you cooked in your own house with your
kids cuz it's really a lot of fun well
if you're not doing any of those things
then you should be checking out blue
apron right now here's how it works
you choose chef's designed recipes and
they deliver fresh seasonally inspired
ingredients you can cook incredible
meals in as little as twenty minutes
so again dinner in as little as twenty
minutes they have quick and easy recipe
options with insanely delicious flavors
folks around the office of amusing blue
apron I wish I were kosher so I could
use it instead lots of folks around the
office are using blue apron and they say
it's just spectacular it's one of the
fastest growing meal to delivery you
know recipes delivery companies in the
country that it's just it's fantastic
it's funny my wife years ago said I wish
I wish there were such a service for me
I wish that I could just go online and
order like the recipe and the
prepackaged ingredients and then blue
aprons an inch like now I wish I were
kosher we feel exactly the same way
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free at blue
aprons comm slash Shapiro that's blue
apron comm slash compare to get your
first three meals for free you're
cooking stuff like crispy chicken
tenders and mashed potatoes
pasta and creamy tomato sauce I mean
this is gourmet stuff you're making in
your own kitchen you're gonna feel like
a chef and you're gonna be able to do it
without having to go to the grocery
store and buy three times too much of
anything every time you go to the
grocery store it's like going to Costco
you come away with three times too much
food of one type and not enough another
type forget that now it's all
pre-portion with blue apron go check it
out right now
blue apron is indeed a better way to
cook and when you go to blue apron comm
slash up here or you get your first
three meals for free so go check it out
right now the entire Democratic
narrative has more from guilt or
innocence down to this forward to
narrative and the narrative is women are
victims so we're back into the war on
women nonsense we got in 2012 when Mitt
Romney said that he had a bi
full of women said he could hire women
and Democrats said that Mitt Romney was
waging a war on women and that that
binder was actually a Stasi folder for
the targeted death of women or some such
nonsense
that's where Democrats are going with us
Susan Collins it turns out is a woman
hey I know I know shocking but Susan
Collins is in fact a woman and she says
listen why doesn't dr. Ford come and
testify she says I hope dr. Ford will
reconsider and testify before the Senate
Judiciary Committee on Monday it is my
understanding the committee has offered
to hold either a public or a private
session
whichever would make her more
comfortable and then Susan Collins came
out she said for saying this she's
received death threats which prompted
Eric's wawel who's a Democratic
Representative to tweet is 24 to tweet
this out he tweeted boo-hoo-hoo you're a
senator who police will protect a sexual
assault victim can't sleep in her home
tonight because of threats where are you
sleeping she's on her own while you and
your Senate GOP colleagues tried to rush
her through a hearing boo-hoo-hoo yet
now this is all about guilt or innocence
guys this isn't about demagoguery at all
speaking about the media's demagoguery
in the media demagoguery on this issue
is just absurd it's absurd you're seeing
purportedly objective news reporters say
the most ridiculous crap I have ever
seen about any allegations of any sort
it really is like fully insane stuff and
Terry Moran was tweeting at me this
morning he's the chief foreign
correspondent for ABC I don't know what
he would know about you know alleged
rape allegations he's the chief foreign
correspondent ABC News I tweeted out the
point is is is not that we should
disbelieve all women we should give
women the presumption of truth but then
we should ask for supporting details and
evidence if we actually give a good damn
about due process or truth itself and
Terry Moran tweeted back at me agreed
one way witnesses are discredited at
trial is through evidence they have
fabricated before people don't just
decide at 51 years old to tell a giant
public live evidence of prior
fabrication in a witness's life is
important so is its absence not
dispositive dispositive but probative so
in other words she hasn't said anything
so we should believe her that's what
he's actually saying that right what
he's saying is you haven't provided any
evidence that she fabricated this so we
should believe it that shifts the entire
burden of proof to Brett Kavanaugh to
disprove an allegation that is so vague
we don't know when or where it happened
this is how the media are treating this
you talk about lack of seriousness how
are the media treat is there in the most
insane possible fashion there are now
two different people who went to school
with the with this accuser who have
suggested that she's telling the truth
but then under questioning it turns out
they don't know anything about Brett
Kavanaugh so one of them is named Gary I
and and here's what she had to say she
she was on CNN she's a former friend and
ex classmate of Cavanaugh's accuser
here's the chance if she's featured on
CNN as a source who would know watch how
this goes you know one of the things
that's been surprising to me as I've
gotten involved in this in the last
couple days is how many women of my
class have come forward to me in this
last few days and said I had similar
experiences in high school and this hits
me very deeply and I spent with my
Kavanagh but with other boys with other
boys in our community
what the actual f what in the world so
this is how this works now at the OJ
trial you say you know what I have had
experiences right the prosecutor says
there are lots of people had experiences
in which people were murdered not by OJ
but by other people and what are you
supposed to do with that like yes lots
of women have had bad experiences with
men in which they were sexually abused
or assaulted
that's awful what does that have to do
with Brett Kavanaugh this is the social
justice left at its finest what social
justice is this is why social justice is
evil social justice is actually evil
because social justice implies that
individual justice is not enough justice
does not need a modifier justice is
about guilt or innocence justice is
about true or false if I accuse senya of
having done something I can't just say
listen listen Senya comes from a
privileged script first of all she
doesn't but if I said to her Senya you
come from a privileged group therefore
it doesn't matter whether you did
something to me it just matters that
your group was privileged and therefore
if anybody of your group ever victimized
anybody of my group therefore you must
have victimized me it doesn't matter if
you're guilty or innocent okay let's say
that some accused somebody from Germany
of doing something to me there's no
evidence it happened
you know what back in the day all of my
grandparents relatives were slaughtered
in Europe by your grandparents all of
them
therefore you raped me well what that
does not follow in the slightest but the
social justice warrior says in the name
of justice in the name of rectifying the
imbalance between men and women Brett
Kavanaugh must be burned at the stake he
is a man there's a woman who made an
allegation burn him burn him right now
string up burn him that's up that's all
we can do in the name of social justice
because there are disproportion between
groups because men have been in charge
of the patriarchy for too long and it
doesn't matter if women have actually if
this woman was victimized by Brett
Kavanaugh that doesn't matter at all
this cuts so against the nature of
Western civilization and cuts so against
the nature of basic humanity and justice
it's insane it's insane
then it wasn't just this woman Gary
who's out there saying well you know
lots of women I know from my high school
they had bad experiences with men said
what what does that have to do with
anything it's not just her there's
another woman who came forward and she
went to high school with Christine Blasi
Ford and she posted a note it's long
note all about how she knew the
Cavanaugh allegations were true
naturally this drove a lot of media
interest and she raised this very very
long note about how all of the
allegations are definitely definitely
true and the media jumps on this they
said oh my god we finally have
confirmation right and it's a long note
and here's what she wrote in the note I
signed this letter it makes me proud to
have attended Holton Arms that's the
high school that Christine Blasi Ford
went to the current situation involving
dr. Christine Blasi Ford and Supreme
Court justice nominee Brett Kavanaugh
touches a very personal nerve and has
unearthed memories good and bad that I
had buried deep from my time at Holton
I graduated from Holton and knew both
Brett and not not well in mark judge I
remember having a bit of a crush on Mark
he had a keen intelligence and sardonic
biting wit one he wasn't drunk which was
often as were lots of teenage guys from
prep I asked him to go to my junior or
senior prom with me can't remember now
which one I just remember how horrible I
felt when he stood me up because he got
bombed in a few hours before the prom
dinner he showed no respect and had no
remorse
apparently in 2018 some things have not
changed unfortunately first of all it's
not a sex assault allegation that said
him being a jerk allegation Christine
Blasi Ford was a year or so behind me I
did not know her personally but I
remember her this incident did happen
yeah this is the part where ever
but he went ok now we're listening many
of us heard a buzz about it indirectly
with a few specific details however
Christine's vivid recollection should be
more than enough for us to truly deeply
know the accusation is true we are all
in some way from that time at least meet
Christine and I applaud her courage and
dignity
the drinking ensconced in the Puritanism
and hypocrisy of that elite privilege
mostly white Catholic Washington Society
was completely out of control we were
teenagers and did really stupid abusive
dangerous things I invite the women who
stepped up in support for Kavanagh in
their letter in addition to writing
about what a good person great athlete
student family man and brilliant
professional Brett Kavanaugh is and he
may well be all those things to reflect
on the use of the word integrity to
describe him and to really think about
who they are supporting and why in my
case even before Christine came forward
I was and still am completely against
his nomination and then and then it says
no man me no matter how fine a person an
upstanding citizen he may be so this
entire letter is basically I hate Brett
Kavanaugh didn't want him on the Supreme
Court and I know the allegations are
true so she says she knows the
allegations are true and the media say
Wow a woman who says she heard about the
this one to the first contemporaneous
account of the story right because the
first time we heard this story
apparently was 2012 when Christine Blasi
floor talked to her therapist so that's
the first time she told anybody outside
of her husband who she once mentioned
this to in like 2002 apparently but now
we have something corroborated a
contemporaneous account of Christine
blaze before talking about being
sexually assaulted by Brett Kavanaugh in
1982 except it's bullcrap how do we know
it's bullcrap cuz you want any PR she
base it she pulled down first of all she
deleted her post then she said well I
didn't really mean for people to take
that all that seriously and then she
went on NPR and this is clip 22 here is
what she had to say about this that it
happened or not I have no idea I can't
say that it did or didn't in my post I
was you know empowered and I was sure it
probably did I had no idea that I would
have to now you know go to the specifics
and defend it before 50 cable channels
and have my face spread all over MSNBC
news and and Twitter I felt empowered
and I didn't feel like I had to
defendant that's pretty much social
justice in a nutshell isn't it the
social justice warriors I felt empowered
so I could speak complete crap directly
from my anus and
wouldn't actually matter whether I was
telling the truth unbelievable I could
actually substitute my my mouth for my
bile duct and everything would be fine
because I felt empowered screw anyone
who believes this way anybody who
believes that your feeling of
empowerment Trump's the truth or basic
human decency is a vile human being is a
vile thing to say
it's a vile nasty horrible thing to say
and it gets even more vile and more
horrible I mean this is it's the worst
smear I've ever seen if they've got no
more evidence than this it's the worst
smear I have ever seen in my life
I mean that bar none that includes the
stuff Democrats had about Romney about
him trying to put people back in Chains
that includes the crap the Democrats
said about John McCain not being able to
use a computer because his hands were
actually wounded in Vietnam it includes
everything to take an accusation that
has no verifying detail and then say you
know what we don't need verifying detail
because it makes us feel empowered you
go straight to hell because you will I
mean this is this is a hell going kind
of thing I mean this is this is a sin of
egregious proportions I'll get two more
of this in just a second but first well
I'm about to stroke out here let's talk
about life insurance okay you actually
need life insurance if you don't want to
if you don't leave your family bereft
when you plotz
you should go check out policy genius
calm right now 40% of Americans still
don't have it so if anything were to
happen their families could be left in a
really difficult financial situation
policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from the
top insurers to find the best policy for
you and when you compare those quotes
you save money it's that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they've placed over
20 billion dollars in coverage and they
don't just make life insurance easy they
also do disability insurance and
renter's insurance health insurance you
care about it they will cover it for you
so if you're looking for a great reason
to buy life insurance there are three
its national life insurance awareness
month rates are two 20-year low and
policy genius makes it super easy go
check it out right now policy genius com
get quotes apply in minutes you can do
the whole thing on your phone right now
and you should before you forget because
once it's done it's done you don't have
to worry about it anymore even if you
die you don't have to worry about it
anymore because your family's taking
care of policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance go check
them out right now policy genius calm
and again get those quotes apply in
minutes I highly recommend it policy
genius.com go check
okay so before we go any further and yes
it goes even further before we go any
further first you're gonna have to go
over to Daily wire and become a
subscriber $9.99 a month gets you a
subscription once you have that
subscription you can see the rest of
this show live the rest of Andrew Clavin
the show live the rest of Michael
Molesey show live you can be part of our
mailbag which we are doing tomorrow when
we do daily wire backstage specials and
you ask questions your live questions
can be asked to guess like Glenn Beck
right speaking of which one is our
Sunday special guest which is why should
subscribe over at youtube or itunes glen
take it away hi I'm Glenn Beck and this
week I'm on the Ben Shapiro show Sunday
special you don't want to miss it it is
a lot of fun and Glenn gets into some
pretty deep territory so go check it out
subscribe at YouTube or iTunes you can
hear our Sundays special with Glenn Beck
also for $99 a year which is cheaper
than the monthly subscription you get
all of those various glories all of
those various wonders Plus this the
leftist here is hot or cold tumblr also
makes julienne fries go check it out
right now it is spectacular
the leftist here's hot or cold tumblr
and again subscribe over YouTube at
iTunes
we always appreciate you leaving a
comment and a review that does help us
go check it out we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so what this has morph into now is
basically Democrats saying that it
doesn't matter whether it's true or
false it promotes a narrative that we
like the narrative the men are evil and
women are innocent and no woman would
ever accuse a man of anything bad and no
man can ever defend himself from
anything there's an article I kid you
not at Yahoo today by Matt guy and the
article essentially suggests that Brett
Kavanaugh should shut it that Brett
Kavanaugh is denial is actually evidence
of his guilt that Brett Kavanaugh is
denial demonstrates that Brett Kavanaugh
doesn't understand the needs of women no
I am not kidding you that's an actual
thing okay it's it's it's truly insane
piece and it's not the only insane piece
today there are a bevy of insane pieces
today coming from people who obviously
do not give any any craps Hey
none as far as as far as whether they
believe that that Kavanagh is guilty or
innocent it's it's a truly insane
it's a truly insane place that we are
now in salon has a piece today called
men are more afraid than ever
why Kavanagh advocates would rather
defend malfeasance than deny it and it's
all about all these people who are
defending Brett Cavanaugh supposed
malfeasance suggesting that you know
people who send in their youth should
not be punished now I don't think that's
the strongest offense for Brett
Kavanaugh I think the strongest defense
for Brett Kavanaugh is it didn't happen
alright that's the strongest defense for
Brenna by the part of this piece that's
crazy is this ok this is a piece I'm
gonna try and find the author Lily
Ruth burrow so here's what she writes
she writes she writes many of us I
include myself are almost persuaded that
men are suffering greatly many of us
have been trained from birth to believe
that men unlike women are long-suffering
and stoic that means that their pain
when they do express it strikes us as
almost holy it took me decades to
realize something like the opposite is
true
it's not that men's pain isn't real it's
that our culture vastly overestimates it
a certain kind of man not getting
exactly what he wants precisely when he
wants it well truly believe he's
suffering more than a woman in pain who
has never been told that what she wants
might matter well this doesn't make him
a liar it does limit him and blind him
to those limits so in other words it
doesn't matter if a man claims something
we can't believe him because there's
been a patriarchal imbalance Molly
has the worst piece I think and that
honestly there's like piece after piece
today that's really really awful there's
a guy named intron t2 Vega writing at
salon talking about Brett Kavanaugh is a
blend of proxy male privilege and a flu
Enza based on an allegation that has
been unproved here's what here's what
this idiot says during his confirmation
hearings Kavanagh has by some accounts
committed perjury he did not he has been
less than forthcoming about his views on
women's rights to control their own
bodies those views are not relevant to a
judge and whether those being those are
being absolute and fully protected by
the Constitution Cavanaugh's record also
shows he does not believe that the civil
rights of black and brown people and
other marginalized groups should be
protected right this is and this is the
reason why we should believe these
allegations the reason we should believe
these allegations is because obviously
Cavanaugh is a bad guy because he
doesn't believe like Democrats believe
Cavanaugh's defenders make excuses for
his alleged sexual assault an attempted
rape of Christine Blasi Ford they are
endorsing and channeling white male
privilege and toxic white masculinity in
America those unearned advantages are
almost exclusive province of those who
are white and male this type of white
entitlements is also amplified and
exaggerated for rich white conservative
heterosexual men now I do want to point
out here they're a bunch of
conservatives who've been saying dumb
stuff like well if you actually did this
then maybe we should still let it go cuz
it was a long time ago I'm not a big fan
of that particular line of argumentation
but the left is jumping on that line
because they want to avoid the actual
implication of all these arguments which
is that it may not have happened at all
and that's where we come to this the
best of all articles this one from Time
magazine I'll get to that one in just a
second first I have to tell you this is
there's an insane accusation from
Huffington Post because there's an
insane accusation from Huffington Post
here is the accusation when you talk
about media coverage that is just
garbaggio this one is from huffington
post you ready for this you're not you
think you are but you're not this is
from Emily Peck Brett Kavanaugh white
female clerks who booked a certain way
Yale student was told a few years ago as
she was prepping to interview for a
judicial clerkship a student at Yale Law
School received a troubling combination
of warning and advice from her
professors about one federal judge in
particular Brett Kavanaugh she was told
liked his female clerks to have quote a
certain look right now Cavanaugh's
nomination to the Supreme Court hangs in
the balance as he
faces in accusation that he sexually
assaulted a girl in high school
the professors preferring the advice are
themselves well known both Jed Rubenfeld
and his wife Amy Chua told this woman
about Cavanaugh's preferences then
Kavanagh was simply known as a
prestigious judge on the DC Circuit
Court of Appeals though neither said the
judge did anything untoward regarding
the women he worked with the student
found their counsel off-putting so in
other words there is no actual
allegation Kavanaugh did anything wrong
but once upon a time people said that
Brett Kavanaugh liked young clerks in
his office to look a certain way and we
don't know there were time is that a
matter of dress is that a matter of what
we have no idea we don't have any clue
hey it's just like how is this anything
short of just a smear this is it I love
this she advised me to be to be and
dress outgoing she strongly urged me to
send her pictures of what I was thinking
of wearing so she could evaluate I did
not well like any employer might want to
know whether you're going to walk into
the office wearing a bra like I don't
even know what this means like Amy Chu
is a big advocate of the idea by the way
that people should dress for success so
maybe that's one of the things that she
is suggesting here we have no idea all
we have is a vague allegation for a
person who's never met Brett Kavanaugh
saying a third party said he liked his
young clerks to look a particular way
this is enough obviously this means that
when he was 17 he tried to rape somebody
clearly clearly the best article of all
comes courtesy of Molly ball hey over at
time.com
and here's where he really gets in the
nub of it Democrats are trying to
restart the war on women meme based on a
fact free allegation made with no
support supporting evidence from the
beginning says Molly ball the women were
determined to be disruptive they're set
Brad Kavanagh looking every bit the
world's most decent man with his even
demeanor and sparkling resume ready to
go through the motions and receive the
benediction of the Senators before him
since the day of his nomination to the
Supreme Court Kavanagh had portrayed
himself as a champion of women
introducing himself to the nation he
emphasized the women he cherished saying
his mother a judge was his ultimate role
model talking about his daughters and
the majority of female law clerks he'd
hired members of the girls basketball
teams he's coached sat in the front rows
behind him
at his Senate confirmation hearing
earlier he recited the names of his
daughter's teammates Anna Quinn Kelsey
Sian Chloe Alex Ava Sophia and Margaret
I love helping the girls grow into
confident play
he had spent a lifetime pushing all the
right buttons and now nothing seemed to
stand between the federal judge and a
seat on the nation's highest court but
one after another
women interrupted still she persisted
protesters popped up in the back of the
room yelling and waving signs before
being hustled out by what by police
women's Senators spoke out of turn
mr. chairman I'd like to be recognized
pled Democrat Kamala Harris of
California to no avail
Cavanaugh sat quietly in the middle of
it at robux smile on his face but the
women it turned out were not done
disrupting him just when the end seemed
in sight his confirmation vote less than
a week away after a hearing that had
turned up no more than the usual
partisan oxd Christine Blasi Ford a
California college professor decided to
put her name to a devastating accusation
charging that some 36 years prior when
they're both in high school Cavanaugh
had sexually assaulted her it was a hazy
accusation hesitantly lodged short on
detail and curiously timed but Ford's
charged shattered Cavanaugh's
carefully-crafted tableau calling into
doubt the image he projected the row of
young girls legs bare in their private
school skirts looked different now okay
so him having a bunch of girls he
coaches in basketball come to a hearing
that looked different maybe Kevin what's
the implication they Kavanagh abused
them is the implication that Kevin I did
something to them
because that's a BS accusation you got
in the evidence Molly ball you're just
gonna throw it out there that all women
are victims Kamala Harris is victimized
just as Christine Blasi Ford was
victimized just as the women on Brick
Cavanaugh's the little girls on Brick
Cavanaugh's basketball team were
victimized women are victims that's the
final pitch that's the election picture
end of story that's what this entire
thing is about all of this boils down to
just a couple of words three really
women are victims that's it that's the
only pitch Democrats have to make here
because they can't make a true or false
pitch they won't even put this lady in
front of a hearing even behind closed
doors they will never talk with senators
they won't provide any supporting
evidence nothing and we're supposed to
buy that we're supposed to sit here and
pretend that that's okay that is okay to
destroy America's unity on the basis of
allegations that have no verifiability
without any questions being asked and
then if you ask a question it means
you're a sexist honestly if you believe
that's what America is all about you do
not understand what America is all about
due process of law is probably the most
key elements of the Constitution of the
United States and now the Democrats
prove they don't like the first or the
second amendments have determined that
they don't actually like the fifth
amendment either they don't like due
process of law it's something that has
to go completely by the wayside what
absolute insanity what absolute insanity
and of course this is all electoral
politics we know this is all electoral
politics and it's it's it's clear this
is what Chris Matthews on MSNBC makes
this absolutely clear Chris Matthews I'm
a mistake says well you know what
happens what if Christine Blasi for
talks right before the election
Democrats or Republicans should dump
Cavanaugh
they send ya who knows I got to the
morning coming like show come here it's
a tiger paper a one crazy my hands that
playing get me a cup of coffee
Kathleen runs hotels I love her she a
woman I mean she's superior come with a
show go I can give a scenario for both
of you the D Republicans will not like
they confirm cabin on next Thursday
he becomes a lifetime member of the
Supreme Court he's in business on the
court deciding issues like roe v--
waited things like that and come this
Sunday night or the Monday night before
the next election the midterm elections
the accuser doctor for appears on
television and gives her full story to a
reporter to an anchor person and it's
deadly okay that's exactly what Chris
Matthews wants to happen but here's the
problem if you don't have any supporting
evidence if the Republicans call your
bluff and got nothing you're toast
you got a problem on your hands okay
time for some things I like it meant
some things that I hate and then we'll
do an uplifting song because man I need
a little bit of calming after after this
episode so time for some things I like
the thing I like I've been reading this
biography of the Adam Smith who is
indeed the father of economics the book
is by Jesse Norman and it's just great
if you've never actually read The Wealth
of Nations or the or his theory of
morals all his work is terrific Adam
Smith is very readable for somebody
who's writing in you know 1773 this is a
guy who's really really readable but if
you if you don't have time for that you
just want to kind of the main idea Jesse
Norman does a great job of sketching out
Adam Smith's life and interspersed
explanations of where his thought comes
from it's a really great primer on both
the idea that there is a that there is a
free-market ideology that exists for a
reason and also that that is backed by a
theory of Moore
sensibility that has roots in Western
civilization so go check it out Adam
Smith father of economics from Jesse
Norman the only part of the book that I
disagree with is a Jesse Norman tends to
be more of a compassionate conservative
type so he says that Adam Smith's
economics is is I think more palliative
more sort of it works more in concert
with with big government programs than I
think Adam Smith actually does but you
can go check it out Adam Smith father of
economics Jesse Norman really really
good book worth reading okay time for
some things that I hate Bernie Sanders
is back and Bernie Sanders is making
crazier and crazier allegations because
here's the thing if Bernie Sanders wants
to keep outflanking his own party he's
going to have to keep moving to the left
they're moving fast to the left so fast
in fact that Bernie Sanders is now
looking like a moderate inside his own
party so it's time for me to break out
the full no I'm Chomsky he's on with
Sarah Silverman who was she ever funny
there there are allegations that Sarah
Silverman was at one point funny I've
never found her particularly humorous
yes humor is subjective and that's my
opinion congratulations
but here's Sarah Silverman whose entire
shtick used to be doing potty mouth
routines in a little girl voice now
she's interviewing Bernie Sanders and
Bernie Sanders says America's a terrible
terrible terrible place somehow he's
been able to become extraordinarily
famous and live a wealthy lifestyle in
this terrible terrible terrible place
without ever doing a shred of useful
work but here he is criticizing the
United States and we can't even use
dirty words the system United States
Senate I can't no it's like we just
stopped little children we go bomb
houses and buses of children and we give
tax breaks to be just no okay so that
that's what we do in America we starve
little children by the way America is
responsible for bringing more people out
of starvation than any force in human
history any force in human history
worldwide poverty has been halved since
1980 that's because of the power of the
American economy and free markets that
he opposes by the way and we all we do
is bomb children you know like when we
actually you know got rid of Saddam
Hussein or when we actually bombed Assad
because he's been murdering children or
when you know we ended World War two or
when we ended the communist regime in
Russia now all of those things really
about America being a terrible terrible
horrible place that's all we are all
America is a place that does terrible
things this is why there
this conflict divisions between left and
right I'm not sure this is bridgeable if
you actually believe Howard Zinn's
version of history America needs to be
replaced as an entity it needs to be
completely torn down and built back up
from the roots by idiots like Bernie
Sanders that's what we absolutely need
because Bundy found that sighs America
is a terrible place a terrible terrible
place where he grew up to again wealth
and privilege and again by any measure
by any global measure the dude lives I
mean he's got a lake house come on and
we're and we're supposed to believe that
America is a terrible awful awful place
he's very upset though that he can't use
dirty words on the Senate floor first of
all I think that we should be able to
use dirty words on the Senate floor
because I'd like to see who exactly like
that this this kind of veneer of
civility in the Senate is a bunch of
nonsense anyway I'd like to see how
these folks use dirty words because I
think that Bernie Sanders Carson would
be so much more entertaining than Bernie
Sanders not cursing I just want to see
Bernie Sanders use like all George
Carlin's words I think it would be very
amusing our economy is just up it's not
pretty and just be incredible but Bernie
said again there's a theory on the left
that every bad that happens is uniquely
American and every good that happens is
unique is universal to humanity so
people rising from poverty human rights
individual rights these are these are
outgrowths of universal visions of
humanity but war famine that's because
of America you have to be a full-fledged
idiot to believe this okay speaking of
full-fledged idiots there's a piece so I
have to comment on this because it's so
absurd there's a piece that has been put
forth by some woman named I think it's
Betty Lou Rebecca Lewis Rebecca Lewis
and it's a piece over at data Society
net which I've never heard of before but
it's getting some play online and it
says alternative influence broadcasting
the reactionary right on YouTube new
data and society a report by researcher
Rebecca Lewis presents data from
approximately 65 political influencers
across 81 channels so I identify the
alternative influencer network an
alternative media system that adopts
techniques of brand influencers to build
audience and sell them political
ideology the idea behind this study is
that YouTube encourages people to go to
the alt-right via things like my show
how do they make this case the way they
make this case they say well Shapiro
once hosted Jordan Peterson Jordan
Peterson was once on tape Rubin Dave
Rubin once had Steven
on Stefan Stefan Molyneux once it was on
with Richard Spencer
therefore Ben Shapiro and Richard
Spencer are linked and we are now
playing six degrees of Kevin Bacon you
know what else I've been on CNN you know
who else has been on CNN Louis Farrakhan
does that mean that Louis Farrakhan and
I are linked and what what absolute
utter horse crap but this is the way
that the media tried to smear people
with connections okay we're gonna we're
not gonna actually go after your ideas
we're gonna go after the fact that you
were once in a room with X and not just
not not that you were friends that
person now that you're like hugging that
person and and you're mirroring their
ideology but you were once in a room
with a person who was in a room with X
yeah the great takedown guys really
really really genius okay final thing
that I hate today so president Trump did
an interview with the hill and he he
said a very silly thing about President
Bush one of my great irritants is that
after the Republican Party spent years
and years and years defending George HW
Bush's a good man
president trenches the Trump has spent
years and years and years tearing
president bush down as though President
Bush is a bad man and I think this is a
bunch of horse crap President Trump said
that Bush bushes Iraq war was the worst
mistake in the history of the country
said the worst single mistake ever made
in the history of our country going into
the Middle East by President Bush Obama
may have gotten soldiers out wrong but
going into me is the biggest single
mistake made in the history of the
country and now you may say that that
going into Iraq was a mistake although
again virtually everybody from both
parties supported it including President
Trump when it first came around but to
say it's the worst mistake in the
history of our country like we had
slavery full-fledged slavery in this
country for four generations from
founding that seems like a pretty big
mistake and then there was Jim Crow
which dominated the south for another
hundred years that seems like a fairly
large mistake it seems like eugenics
programs on the state level it seems
like that might have been kind of a
large mistake it seems like in terms of
foreign policy
you know abandoning Iraq and letting
Isis rise might have been kind of a huge
mistake not bombing the tracks on the
way to Auschwitz that might have been a
big mistake during World War Two
shutting our borders to Jews trying to
escape that might've been a mistake
you know Japanese internment that
could've been kind of a big mistake
she's like I made a few mistakes but
this this outsized rhetoric with regard
to the war in Iraq all it does is
promote a foreign policy that is
I think in ideology not accurate and in
some ways unhinged you can disagree with
the war in Iraq and say that it was a
war that was unnecessary and still
recognized that that it was not the kind
of mistake that the Trump is making it
out to be a historic mistake of
cataclysmic proportions that's just not
accurate okay time for a quick song
because come on we all need a song
because it's been a long show and a long
week and I just came back from a really
nice yom kippur by the way like yom
kippur was it was really great I got to
spend in Sheol just praying and
convening with God and and pouring out
my heart to to God and that was a really
nice thing it's actually really it's
when my dad used to say was his favorite
holiday used to think that's crazy cuz
he can't eaten you can't drink and it's
quickly growing on me anyway the the
Psalms chapter 9 that's we do one a week
so we're all the way up to chapter 9
it's all about thanking God with all my
heart it says I would Rose Joyce and
exult with you I will sing your praises
to the Most High name when my enemies
draw backward they stumble and are
destroyed from before you for you have
performed my judgment my cause you sat
on the throne a judge of righteousness
you rebukes nations you destroy the
wicked man you erase their name forever
and ever the enemy has been destroyed
swords exist forever and you have
uprooted the cities their remembrance
has lost but the Lord shall set forever
he has established his throne for a
judgement but he judges the world with
righteousness kingdoms with equity and
the Lord shall be a fortress for the
crushed a fortress for times of distress
I think that the the what's what's great
about this particular Psalm is that he
suggests that it's not just individuals
who are judged nations are judged as
well at the very end of the psalm it
says arise O Lord let man have no power
may the nations be judged for your anger
o Lord place mastery over them what the
nations know that they are forever
mortal man there's this feeling that
that I think a lot of people have both
left and right and nations are eternal
no matter what we do a nation cannot go
the way of a dodo bird a nation will
simply exist there will be no
consequences to the bad decisions that
we make the reality of course the
nations are made up of individual human
beings if those individual human beings
pursue bad purposes it will tear the
nation apart my view of God is that God
is active in the universe but he's also
in it he's in eventualities
God is the predictable result of the
actions that you take that are immoral
and the and the actions that we take
that are immoral that tear down our own
nation from within once we have hollowed
selves out then of course it's a
reminder that we are all mortal and in
the end the nation collapses along with
the individuals who comprise that nation
alrighty we'll be back here tomorrow
with all the latest plus the mailbag I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing